vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel bien qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus le si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter dati seach ph quentin
avec moi de me plante on est encore en
mode confinement comme toute la
population du québec
mais ça nous en donne cette semaine deux
fois par une boutique de linge qui ont
plus de cinquante boutiques au québec
partout au nouveau-brunswick également
vous achetez ces temps ci c'est le
confinement mais vous pouvez acheter
votre linge en ligne sur la plateforme
sur leur site en dehors du sport bostock
cette veste ici ce t-shirt là puis
pauvres et les tee shirt basique leur ph
poste et c'est tout un jeu blanc oui
jean louis cheveux blancs puis c'est de
la bombe moi je trouve ramasser des
bombes et zic vraiment gentille et même
poser parce que c'est une commande ici
mais je trouve que d'habitude la coupe
est pas parfaite le la coupe est
parfaite pile à la qualité est bonne sur
mon iphone ça c'est un conseil fashion
girl 0 fashion mais avoir un bon
basique c'est le best pour bons baisers
que c'est le best avoir des bons
basiques avec avec juste là une bonne
couple ça fait le diable a pas besoin
d'avoir derrière les afro funk il a
juste avant des bas mais moi ce gros je
les laisse un gros chalet lévis oui
c'est pas un baiser que c'est une marque
sauf que reste un gros gilet noir c'est
très dans mon style c'est wade qui le
choisit pis j'adore ce gros gilet le jeu
le porte constamment bref également la
veste que je passe ici
bref des hangars 29 qui avec une code
promo sf qu'ils veulent avoir 15 % de
rabais sur vos achats en ligne vont vous
en voyez surtout pas banal et cette
entreprise québécoise donc on parle
beaucoup d'achat local sensible c'est
l'occasion d'encourager une entreprise
québécoise
puis c'est ce qui est une autre
entreprise québécoise a encouragé cv
gagnent les pop lancer mon entreprise on
fait des plats surgelés durant la
quarantaine des plats surgelés qu'on
livre chez vous donc on a juste des bons
commentaires pour l'instant on a réussi
à mettre en place un bon service de
livraison qui les place sont justes
packing bon fait que si vous voulez
avoir des pleurs chez vous pour que ça
peut dépanner des fois on sait pas trop
quoi manger on n'est pas là l'épicerie
parce qu'en ce moment c'est un peu un
rôle à l'épicerie vegan mais pas plateau
triple w point bnpp point c'est un puits
vous allez pouvoir commander vos plans
mais 25 % des profits de cette
entreprise de services de livraison
l'homme et son ampleur surgelés aux
professionnels de la santé pour
favoriser leur bateau est en ce moment
aux lignes de front je sais que souvent
ils font des longues heures puis on peut
nécessairement le temps de manger donc
on leur offre sur en ce moment donc allé
voir ce triple w point bnpp point ca
sinon on impétueux le dom cette semaine
ont fait un podcast et une basse toit
puis moi où est ce qu'on va imploser sur
pétrone donc si vous voulez plus de
contenu si vous voulez nous entende
parler sur un support it one super tu es
sûr pétrone c'est là où est ce que
d'hommes puis moi on déconne un petit
peu plus mais on parle de nos affaires à
nous fait que si vous voulez avoir
savoir un petit peu plus sur nous
et moins axé sur un éviter évidemment
c'est là que ça se passe du contenu
exclusif là dessus trois pièces par mois
le lien votre description de la vidéo ça
dans le fond et continent d'écouter ça
nous fait plaisir de partager cette
période de crise puis semaine au podcast
on a reçu ou c'est vrai j'oubliais aussi
d'oublier ça on a aussi catherine fourni
qui tu n'es c'est la plus jeune femme à
avoir été élue à l'assemblée nationale
de l'histoire du québec
elle a 28 ans elle est vraiment ces
députés députés pardon qui maintenant
est dépendante et au pq et le quitter
maintenant se dit députée indépendante
souverainiste une femme impressionnante
brillante femme de tête de carrément une
super belle conversation sur justement
ben vraiment la crise sur les québec en
général sur la souveraineté sur comment
qu'on peut réformer améliorer le système
politique dans lequel on est super la
conversation que j'ai que j'adorais
vraiment ouais tout à fait ça nous a
rejoué beaucoup fait que déjà j'ai trop
parlé
je m'excuse pour ce sans plus attendre
bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
ouais c'est parti merci catherine d'être
là d'avoir accepté de venir sur notre
podcast
ça fait un bout qu'on était sur notre
liste d'invités mais on attendait
d'avoir un moment où est-ce que ça
allait être un os que politiquement on
voulait avoir une discussion avec toi
puis je trouve qu'aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment dans la situation actuelle sur
une bonne occasion de parler la société
québécoise
ça ressemble à la vie de député le en ce
moment c'est que c'est quoi ton
quotidien
c'est tellement différent de ce qu'on
peut vivre à l'avenir parce que moi
comme député je s'habitue et habiter
constamment en deux endroits et je me
promène constamment en tongs et bien
contre la faute à chaque semaine je
pense que j'ai jamais été aussi stable
c'est uniquement depuis plusieurs années
qui dit et redit notre étude d'un député
c'est de rencontrer les gens et on est
toujours fameuse des poignées de main et
c'est vrai dire on est habitués ils
devaient courir à 100 milles à l'heure
avec d'employés l'événement du jour au
lendemain se faire arrêter
mambé temps mais tellement qu pays parce
que plus que jamais entre que moi dans
mon expérience de 3 ans et commun comme
député je n'ai jamais eu autant de
demandes des citoyens donc en même temps
on travaille extrêmement fort mais si
vraiment différent c'est un peu comme
tout le monde on est comme chez nous
souvent même à des barrettes à la limite
et on répond à toutes les demandes qu'on
des réseaux sociaux via les courriels et
les téléphones qui s'investit vraiment
diamétralement opposées au quotidien
qu'on a absolument j'ai vu que tu avais
une tournée de pour donner du
désinfectant ce qui distingue en avait
besoin et puis mais sinon concrètement
qu'est ce que tu peux faire pour aider
les gens parce que presque plus pour
être en contact avec grand monde non
cette histoire là contact encore de rôle
parce que on est tellement présent sur
les réseaux sociaux au québec on est en
contact avec les gens mangent et
plusieurs dizaines de personnes qui
m'écrivent à chaque jour que ce sont les
citoyens qui ont des questions si ça
peut être aussi bas que j'ai vraiment
répondu me donner la bonne information
déjà en mettant dans une situation
financière précaire et qui ont poli
moyens par exemple d'aller faire les
prix sont pas nécessairement des
habitués sont venues des organismes
communautaires des banques alimentaires
mais non les aigris bonne personne pour
les respecter mais au delà même des
citoyens
on sait qu'en taxi par beaucoup
d'entreprises dans nos circonscriptions
déjà tu vas l'avoir oui l'information
gouvernementale mais souvent ceux et
celles qui vont tomber dans les quatre
différents programmes et qui sont peu un
auquel ont déjà son spécial auquel on
attend c'est nous n'aurons de dirhams a
pris ces derniers n'ont paris soit au
gouvernement soit notre contact avec les
différents ministères directement pour
réussir à sensibiliser nos leçons les
ministres à leurs problèmes qui à leur
faire une place dans leur programme pour
les citoyens et les entreprises mais
aussi les organismes
c'est en tout parlé de l'idée même
secteur mais en attendant les premiers
jours de la crise beaucoup d'organismes
communautaires du monde qui m'ont
contacté que ce soit par téléphone ou
encore par les réseaux sociaux pour
maintenir je manquais il y avait une
reverb très limitée puisqu'elle a tout
les désinfectants le révérend votre
réseau de la santé était impossible pour
eux d'y avoir accès le travail avec mon
équipe ça a été de contacter afin que
toutes les filles de la montérégie pour
savoir si eux pourraient pas mettre la
main à la pâte pour aider justement à
cause de voir du désinfectant
parce que les gens peuvent maintenant
faire maison et tous les ingrédients
qu'on a besoin pour créer du
désinfectant ils sont tous en rupture de
stock
si ça peut te plaît à nos batailles mais
c'est toute démarche elle confié
dans l'ombre était de maintenir en
contact récemment visités des médiations
de sa stricte the lights au bon endroit
c'était super intéressant parce que ça
fait de nous les députés des gentils
achetons en premier à clément qui
vraiment on arrive à amener les gens
semblent tu dis vrai que c'est très
gratifiant style de savoir qu'il ya une
attraction puis ce dernier d aussi beaux
résultats
ouais c'est tu parles de 10 teariki qui
sont mis à faire du désinfectant moi je
trouve que c'est un des exemples
parfaits de qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce
qu'on voit en ce moment je trouve le
temps au québec moi j'ai jamais été
aussi fier d'être québécois que durant
cette crise le thé de la façon que tout
le monde semble mettre l'épaule à la
roue le pti pour pour se sortir de ce
truc là puis beaucoup d'entreprises
comme tu parles crise car yann justement
qui qui veulent utiliser leur expertise
pour s'aider soi je trouve ça vraiment
cool je trouve que ça fait ça se
concentre là dessus tout c'est du
positif à tirer de la vente est retiré
aussi pour la suite des choses pour
continuer à avancer après sur tellement
petit troquet là la seule tactique on va
aller se présentement et c'est juste
boules de niles tadic qui convoie des
entreprises qui prennent des superbes
initiatives comme il existe ici
justement qui ont créé une nouvelle
formule de désinfectant pour venir aider
les lieux d'autres entreprises qui
voient site qui elle aussi a le goût des
dp ou bien les employés de certaines
entreprises vont sensibiliser leur
complot ayant pour délit peut-être que
nous on pourrait contribuer de telle ou
telle façon
je donne un exemple ait dans une
épicerie dans ma circonscription est une
dame du travailleur et le duo plus que
ce que je faisais quelques certaines
entreprises de fer qui l a demandé à son
directeur
si eux ne pourrait pas aussi mettre
l'épaule à la roue
son directeur accepter qu'ils me
contacter pour me demander de trouver
douze familles dans le besoin du culte
et financière en raison de la crise
actuelle pour leur offrir une vitrine
gratuitement et 10 et j'ai eu des petits
gestes comme ceux qui manquaient je
pense que ça devient
la solidarité devient contagieux on voit
les belles initiatives qui seront tout
le monde vous souhaite contribuer et et
pour ceux qui sont capables succès tant
en bonne position je sens un peu comme
est comme les extreme world
mais c'est beau de voir que les gens
saisissent la gestion stabilité d'élan
collectif dans lequel une somme que moi
mais oui puis andres a donné sport
justement mouchetés un peu
désillusionnés ont dit que j'avais la
vision qu'il n'y avait rien de plus
important que le profit ou que l'argent
qui lie la question économique pour pour
la majorité des gens est ce que pour les
entreprises puis là on en a la preuve
que que plusieurs sont prêts à faire des
sacrifices au plan économique si c'est
pour aider un prochain aussi c'est pas
vraiment des questions ou c'est
important que la santé ou même de la vie
ou la mort des gens natifs et qui sait
pas ici question de chiffres finalement
il est quand même une solidarité qui
plus forte que ceux entre nous tiens
clairement ça coûte ça coûte assez cher
à cette entreprise nommée quelques
exemples mais j'en ai plein c'est juste
moi longue et partout au québec comme
cela on le voit partout sur les réseaux
sociaux
mais il ya le coup justement pour ces
entreprises l'homme en même temps et
mettre justement l'épaule à la roue
évidemment ce qui est j'ai beau avoir en
ce moment tu parle de justin qui ont
reculé un petit peu le 44 tu parles du
travail des députés qui est souvent sur
la route le convoi en ce moment dans les
entreprises beaucoup de monde
justement j'écoutais hier à tout le
monde en parle le gars qui dans l'oeil
du dragon je sais quoi son nom non plus
mais des dragons qui explique est en
train de revoir avec son entreprise
le loyer de ces opérations parce qu'il
se rend compte qu'en ce moment par zoom
comme ça c'est vraiment plus efficace
puis tout le monde travaille aussi bien
est ce que tu penses que ceux pour le
métier députés pour le trail des députés
va être un
un point game challenger mais va être
quelque chose qui va être au moins remis
en question l'espèce de constant besoin
d'aller à l'assemblée nationale est
constant besoin de revenir tu as une
construction pitié de fer sur toutes les
semaines je sais pas si tu pour le
travail des députés ça va réellement
changer parce que bon c'est sûr qu'il va
peut être important qu'on se retrouve
l'ensemble des députés pour elle et des
bottes et parlementaires
par contre moi je suis vraiment d'avis
qu'on devrait aider cette crise là pour
justement avant l'interview de
développer des nouveaux outils
technologiques qui nous permettrait par
exemple de faire gptd commission
parlementaire justement par le biais de
nouvelles technologies ou encore imposer
des questions parfois plus virtuel ou
écrites et déjà le corps n'est pas
tellement mis de l'avant actuellement
dans le système un peu plus classe et
donc oui à peu sa peinture est une belle
occasion pour voir ce qu'il est possible
de faire
par contre j'ai pas l'impression qu'on
veut nécessairement changer du tout au
tout c'est sûr que pour le travail de
député ça complique un peu les choses
mais par contre comme cela vient dinan
plusieurs entreprises ont fait une
énorme différence
c'est non seulement les entreprises vont
tomber quand même beaucoup d'argent
c'est décider du chemin de migrer en
bonne partie vers le télétravail parce
qu'ils ont des espaces de bureaux -
duras a occupé donc un loyer moins
important aussi qui est ça veut
tellement améliorer la qualité de vie
des gens et si je lisais du terme et
seulement 20% mais d'employés je prenais
une journée par semaine en télétravail
mais déjà en baisse très beau coup là la
congestion de 1,10 turquie était au bord
du rhône mental c'est vraiment génial
dit parce qu'il fait rire unique c'est
vraiment direct sur la production de gaz
à effet de serre parce que encore
aujourd'hui que bien que les transports
un représentant la l'attrait la très
grande partie dans le fond de la
politique en général
certains y avait des petites qui sont
pris en ce moment qui qui qui vont qui
auront avantage qui vont être gardés
justement tibet notamment seul
télétravail notamment surtout la chaîne
locale dit qu'on a on en parle de plus
en plus de plus en plus important et
crucial et consommer la carte
puis juste pas un pet comme ça juste
cette fierté loucedé québécois la
traversée des valeurs qui font peut-être
été un peu plus présente les prochains
mois mais je pense que t'en penses
je suis vraiment d'accord je pense que
tout le monde médecins justement dans
cette espèce de d'élan que les six ans
maman viendrait autre que pour notre
génération c'était la première fois
qu'on dit quelque chose comme ça où on
sent vraiment qu'il fait là ses directs
élective qui doit passer d'abord et
avant tout si on met toutes en ce moment
deux copines ou libertés individuelles
pour dans le fond le bien-être de la
société en général action que oui je
pense que ça me fait beaucoup réfléchir
ces valeurs que vous citez en ce moment
je suis toujours fiable québécoise en ce
moment particulièrement quand je vois
qu'ils déploient dit quand on voit aussi
par exemple la semaine passée ont des
vues par google tv quoi on est accueilli
en pions du réseau des anciens sociale
le choc était moins négative on veut
respecter
oui à venise est passé on voit que les
gens comptage visant à répondre aux
consignes qui d'après un site
parce que justement au niveau 2 de ce
seuil et hélicocéan des vous quelle
mesure elle pour lesquelles on fait des
sacrifices mais ça fonctionne c'est
vraiment règlements liés je pense à la à
la scène bastille comme ceux ci ce qui
est une souverainiste convaincu c'est
parce que cette crise est vraiment le
peut raviver un peu sa flamme de je vais
sauter sur la question pour que la
rediriger ensuite quelques mois - je
suis
je souverainiste depuis longtemps puisse
allah comme disparus un petit peu en moi
parce que je trouvais que c'était plus
une question qui m'apparaissait comme
étant urgente urgente et qui
m'apparaissait comme étant un nécessaire
aux motifs dans les dernières années
par contre on a reçu jean martin aussant
sur le sur le podcast
puis après une conversation avec lui
c'est là quand même à flamme bleue et a
été réactivé un petit peu puis tout ça
pour culminer jusqu'à maintenant
ou est ce que dans une crise comme celle
là on aurait aimé avoir le complet
contrôle-t-il de notre situation qu'on
aurait aimé que le gouvernement qui qui
fait une job extraordinaire je trouve on
pourra en reparler tout à l'heure mais
je trouve que c'est une gestion de crise
irréprochable mais qu'on aurait aimé
avoir le contrôle complète et puis j'ai
l'impression que ça ça ça relance à mon
avis l'urgence de la question de la
question nationale est évidemment
totalement d'accord avec toi disco mon
frère je comprends qu'on se demande
effectivement si c'est vrai que la crise
en ce moment met en exergue dans le fond
la nécessité pour le québec tout va être
pleinement en détention de l'ensemble de
ces moyens sont de vue justement que
notre gouvernement cubain qui a été très
actif au début puis a été parmi les
premiers les premiers des tonnes vont à
as posé comme véritable leader pour
freiner la propagation du virus
mais en même temps maintenant de tout
cas bien h 10 c'est vrai qu'on n'avait
pas l'ensemble de nos moyens
témoin comme souverainiste et ce samedi
c'est qu'on a encore moins de raison
d'avoir un complexe par rapport au
québec on est tout à fait capable de
gérer une humaine qui s'est même
important qu'on puisse avoir tous ces
moyens là parce qu'on aurait pu agir
encore plus rapidement petite histoire
mieux ta question des frontières bien
sûr même si qu'on parle de deux
programmes va
on aurait pu avoir des programmes ou
c'est bien mais on est toujours un peu
en train de dédoubler les choses et on
aurait pu avoir un geste qu'on peut être
plus concertée d'avoir des réponses plus
rapides
1 pour les citoyens dimanche six hommes
tout ça bien été mais je crois qu'au
delà de ces mesures là que tu as dis
vraiment la crise c'est à quel point on
a un état québécois qui est solide
si oui on a le gouvernement on à
monsieur leubou on a l'ensemble des
ministres dont je suis d'accord avec toi
une excellente job mais en même temps et
toutes ses équipes de fonctionnaires
derrière et qui sont tellement bien
formique dont on doit essayer de l'état
en on estime entre on a chialé côté
fonctionnaires mais il faut dire que je
suis toute l'équipe justement des
fonctionnaires qui agite derrière nos
gouvernements tombent en place qui sont
réactifs qui vous permet d'avoir une
aussi bonne réponse à la crise puis donc
et effectivement si je pense que ça
c'est encore une fois la preuve comme
quoi le québec aurait vraiment tout âge
et à gérer lui-même comme tu fais quoi
on est capable on vois qu'on s'identifie
tué beaucoup de fierté québécoise en ce
moment j'espère évidemment comme c'est
vrai mais c'est sûr que ça va pouvoir se
matérialiser je me permets d'être
invitée satisfait perdurer la crise
j'espère il faut quand même aussi
relativiser à s'inquiéter
louis legault fait un excellent travail
puis ceux perçus tout le monde en
convient n'empêche que puis on le
critiquait beaucoup trudeau début la
crise qui a pas réagi assez rapidement
ce n'empêche que les conséquences
puis les décisions sont beaucoup plus
larges au niveau fédéral c'est parce qu'
une décision ou une action le sait
comment quand l'appliquent sur
l'ensemble du pays et ce tandis que le
travail de legault reste plus un travail
de beaucoup de communication de
transparence d'information
donc j'ai en même temps je comprends
cette carte est là mais j'ai un petit
malaise quand on compare les deux parce
que les implications et de palisson
quand même pas les mêmes le même temps
encore drôle parce que le gouvernement
du québec a quand même dit gerri
un tout ce qui concerne mantoue astier
restriction des libertés individuelles
c'est quand même possible que ça oui
c'est le domaine de la santé
oui c'est les services sociaux la santé
publique tout ça mais c'est pas tant que
ça peut paraître moins d'accord pour
dire qu'il ya vraiment un gros niveau de
différences entre les deux puis au
contraire que c'est pas parce que
c'était des compétences par exemple qui
va lever du gouvernement du canada que
justement on n'aurait pas été mieux de
l'égérie ici au québec
je pense que justement d'être plus
petits pays et c'est vrai qu'elle canada
dry avis très différent et le fait
d'être un plus petit pays
ça nous permet une plus grande agilité
depuis plusieurs amis on vit beaucoup
porté à modifier un peu les grands états
mais maintenant que les petites nations
comme le québec
au contraire on aurait plus de l'agility
pion de plus des on peut on peut mieux
servir et on peut plus s'adapter
rapidement parce que justement mairie
qui nous est propre
donc même si le québec était un pays
dans ce que la wii avait des enjeux
importants gérer comme par exemple les
relations et à la 108e dans le cas qui
nous occupe présentement sauf tout la
relation avec moi si tu aimes
mais justement avec l'agilité d'un pays
je pense que ça me permettrait d'avoir
une meilleure réponse des plus bâtiment
mais j'ai l'impression que dans ce cas
cité pilote c'est sûr qu'on en parle
dans une situation jamais vue puis on
parle d'un problème qui peut-être y
arriveras jamais du moins de notre vive
entier mais j'ai l'impression que dans
des situations comme ceux justement
l'avantagé d'avoir un gouvernement plus
facilement malléable ou qui peut plus
facilement s'adapter aurait eu un gros
impact si on considère par exemple qu'un
juste pour la question des frontières là
si au moment où est ce que toutes les
mesures avaient été prises au québec les
frontières du québec avait alors été
fermée pour des vols provenant de
l'étranger
mettons le site je pense si trois quatre
jours de différence entre la fermeture
des frontières
fédéral pour les voyages les vols de
l'étrange et apprécié en tout les
mesures qui ont été prises au québec
mais quatre jours d'un seul le nombre de
personnes qui débarquent ici j'ai
vraiment l'impression que ça leur fait
un impact majeur cette espèce de fenêtre
de quatre jours le tiens on parle de on
parle d'un virus qui se transmettent
tellement rapidement à tellement de
personnes que ces quatre jours là j'ai
l'impression aurait pu vraiment faire un
changement tir mais que là c'est quand
quatre jours d'ouverture de frontières
qui ont été là dans un espèce de de flou
de comme l on regarde comment ça avance
puis on on se trompe pas trop parce que
les percussions sont trop grandes
économiquement c'est alors qu'ici on
avait déjà annoncé beaucoup de mesures
qui allaient de la vente je pense que ça
quatre jours qui était quand même
quelques pas été atteint non clairement
ça faisait quatre jours justement que
françois legault demande elle justin
trudeau de procéder de cette façon là
qu'il ya aussi toutes les consignes
jette à envoyer aux douanes canadiens
que ce soit les doigts ts les voix aux
aéroports on a eu beaucoup de
témoignages sont par exemple des filles
qui revenait du talent y est je pense 4
5 jours avant que le confinement soit un
pauvre et qu'ils avaient eu aucune
information sur le corona virus selon le
ser demandé c'est revenez d'italie puis
de faire attention à leur santé
grosso modo était-ce aussi aidé rectif
qu'on aurait pu on aurait pu envoyer
bien avant tu ressentais vraiment un
décalage au but c'est aujourd'hui comme
j'ai mes opinions sentais vraiment
décalage dans la prise je trouvais
intéressant justement qu'est-ce qu'on le
regarde justement sur la sangle de
souveraineté parce que lors d'un exemple
concret tangible de qui et comment
comment conserver différent si on était
un pays tandis que ça donne vraiment un
argument évidemment concret et solide
tandis que j'ai l'impression que dans
ces courses souverainiste
parce que depuis longtemps mais je pense
qu'il faut être d'accord avec cela c'est
qu'il ya un peu de l'absence d'arguments
ou bien on est vite on hésite où on veut
pas trop en parler parce qu'on est un
petit peu gêné
c'est comme on veut faire la
souveraineté mais on nous explique
jamais vraiment la raison derrière ce
c'est qu'on avantage qu'en désavantage
cpie notamment par les péages parler de
jean martin aussant tantôt moi justement
mon petit monde éveil souverainiste a
été à travail égal à l'époque chan vers
ce type tamiflu dans la crise étudiante
justement pis mais lui chaque fois qu'il
parle et donner des arguments concrets
il pas pragmatique avec des chiffres les
chiffres
puis voici les avantages à être
souverain s'est dit c'est on dresser
comme une révélation c'était comme si
acquis non c'est pas juste une affaire
de coeur et de fierté oui c'est
important cette fierté le mais c'est pas
juste avec l'émotion qu'il faut gagner
les gens c'est au cip avec des arguments
avec des chiffres les gones économistes
aussi il a justement cette situation
nous amène un petit peu le concret de
tous au dessus mais mais je trouve ça
dommage justement que jamais dans disco
public sinon on entend des arguments en
faveur de la souveraineté c'est comme
ceux ci n'ont carrément il ya comme une
espèce de shine s'est installé dans le
mouvement souverainiste je pense que
jean martin justement le bien ne vient
expliquer puis mon style je trouve que
j'aime dans le temps qui écrit sur
youtube je pense qu'il existe à radier
beaucoup de jeunes en général son charme
avec ses arguments plus pragmatique est
vrai que ça manque beaucoup dans le dans
les courses souverainiste en général
mais comme le dit mon but est le mot
concret est encore beau visage humain
comme si tu devais faire des boules
cours entre estaing qui ont convaincu
c'est souvent ce qu'on voit
malheureusement dans nos mouvements et
ses besoins d'aller rejoindre une
nouvelle personne avec ce genre de
discours le marchand effectivement
beaucoup sinon de l'action ensemble
comment transformer des arguments en
situation réelle
puis là bas c'est sûr que les foyers des
contextes piqué qui arrivent comme
l'enseignement la crise qui viennent
vraiment comme même beaucoup plus
concret un enfant une question de
contexte dans tout ça et ces classes
leadership
j'ai l'impression que peut-être que
naïvement mais j'ai l'impression que ce
ça va survivre à la crise tellement
j'écoute les points de presse de de
legault à tous les tous les après midi
ils vivent là je passe deux jours
c'était c'était quasiment un point de
presse sur une liste l'autiste et genre
c'était c'était quasiment la main sur le
coeur devant le drapeau à le tester mais
c'est puis j'ai pas du tout été élu avec
ceux qui planait dans sa campagne mais
là c'est comme on sent qu'il ya une
espèce de de ralliement derrière notre
premier ministre le tpiy puis c'est
quand même c'est quand même touché comme
témoignage ces pistes et inattendu
surtout lui me rappelle plus c'est quand
je pense que vu le jour avec un sport
qu'il fait vendredi mais aussi jouets
des genres dont ils ont besoin avec la
ration d'indépendance et on était
vraiment métier le goût c'est en france
que fait penser à toi 30 août spectacle
en dormant bti transmis le goût avant
les stars grand souverainiste épargner
les plus mal mais précisé qu on les
appelait au parti québécois et lui il y
avait semblé mettre de côté le bon y
apparaîtrait nationale est justement
dans ce remake mangé j'ai bien au devant
la suite moi je pense qu'il y en a
beaucoup au sein de son gouvernement qui
partage le même avis mais bon tu sais ça
peut nous juste que si ce nouveau
mouvement si une nouvelle vague de
souveraineté souverainiste ça peut pas
être là les mêmes visions les mêmes
arguments que c'était à 91 95
c'était parce que le québec qui pas
pareil qui sait si un mouvement qui
inclut tout le monte parce que de plus
en plus les québec et métissée qui ça va
être de plus en plus pis si quelqu'un
qui pot blancs francophones sans peau
interpellé par ce projet ne sera jamais
il faut que ça transcende ce absolument
d'accord c'est pourquoi est-ce-que
excuse moi je vais pas de couper c'est
avec zoom ça
fait discuter en ce moment mais j'ai
l'impression que des fois qu'ils
comparent leur souveraineté au 21e
siècle on fait des rapprochements avec
des dés soient des groupes des fois
d'extrême droite outils et des fois en
europe justement là sous les mouvements
nationalistes est beaucoup plus la
droite justement un petit peu plus comme
en france avec le pen est généreux mais
ici ça jamais été sous 7 jours et est
même l'hiver suivant le la souveraineté
les personnes les partis souverainistes
comme le pq c'était vraiment plus la
gauche qsc la gauche mais n'empêche que
il ya un peu ce rapprochement le qui
l'important de plus en plus fait entre
le mot souveraineté nationalisme qui ces
idéologies idéologie le qui justement
comment qu'on commet condé fait c'est
comment qu'on contre mouvaux la
souveraineté sans se faire traiter d
eczéma ou des sites de soutien
mais cette lacune par exemple qu'on a
beaucoup d influence de leur grotte où
le monde nationalistes ne veut pas dire
la même chose qu'au québec il faut
toujours se rappeler que le nationalisme
comme itunes une nation minoritaire
c'est différent mais sincèrement de pas
de par sa nature
le nationaliste campent déjà été il
affirmé
c'est autre chose à mon sens est déjà là
il ya une grande une grande différence
est en ce moment à télé québec on est
vraiment un îlot francophone en amérique
du mans et si on line à retardement ou
au sein du canada
maintenant comment parler librement de
façon beaucoup plus positive en short il
faut avoir un discours différent comme
tu le disais tantôt des années 80 et des
années 90 un cours oui prête inclusive
parce que le québec a changé même depuis
un deux lycées depuis ces années là je
pense qu'il faut que ça s'entende je
pense qu'il faut que ça se voit
c'est dans nos actions parce que si on
entend trop souvent mettant dans le
mouvement légendaire homme il faut
inclure tout le monde a dit mais qu'est
ce que tu fais pourtant c est ce qu on
veut vraiment essayé de convaincre
chemin ou d'aller parler du projet
d'indépendance et à des gens de
différentes origines on en parle souvent
c'est trop peu vraiment ces contacts
établis entre que dans dans plusieurs
milieux est je crois qu'on doit viser
beaucoup je sais maintenant ce maman par
la crise et un tour des points ça
mettait en ligne à la conscience qu'on
peut avoir dans notre état québécois
c'est la seule d'actes et l'entrain qui
nous anime est ce que c'est des valeurs
qui sont positifs et va miser sur la
confiance
miser sur l'ambition si je pense qu'on
est capable de faire on peut réaliser
nos plus grandes aspirations québec les
québécois se démarquer riise et
l'international et je suis convaincu
qu'on peut avoir une influence pour ce
disque partie normalement c'est là avec
la queue 19 on a vraiment été des
leaders s'il ya des gens sur mac se sont
inspirés ce que m alors dans le monde
embourbée lit pour voir qu'est ce qu'on
fait est bien ce film agissements québec
procède à l'organisation mondiale de la
santé ou dans d'autres instances de l'ue
ont muté pour partager vraiment y fait
de bien chez nous puis de pouvoir
inspirer à beaucoup plus grande échelle
les autres pays du monde c'est dans ce
moment parle beaucoup du virus mais
bientôt aussi si on revient à la normale
avant tout la question de
l'environnement qui veut prendre sa
place aussi
j'ai encore l'être québec que jouer un
rôle qui est important donc je pense que
c'est vraiment inquiétant de commettre
qu'on se représente
sinon on peut seulement ici si nous mais
balmont puis les influences qu'on est
capable d'exercer
c'est un super point de thé souvent on à
l'espèce de d'idées que ce soit pour les
changements climatiques ou pour la
gestion de la crise actuelle t on au
diane's autre peu importe ce qu'on fait
même si on le fait super bien ça aura
pas d impact planétaire c'est justement
on en parle et je pense encore une fois
dans le podcast avec jean martin ou est
ce qu'on se dit c'est pour
l'environnement par exemple le même si
nous demain matin on réduit nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 50%
on est vraiment marginale dans
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre
global ti mais le point qui est que ta
main en ce moment de dire oui mais on
peut devenir un exemple à suivre si on
peut donner un exemple à suivre pour ces
choses le kiki ceci ya de quoi il ya de
quoi être fier
quoi
chercher de la motivation dans cette
histoire là un exemple à suivre sur
l'intégration des gens qui arrivent ici
tu es l'exemple à suivre dans dans la
place des femmes l'exemple exemple à
suivre dans toutes ces choses le puits
je pense que ça s'arrange
ça rend tout plus concret on dirait que
de dirhams et là moi je roule en voiture
électrique mais en chine il faut lutter
se passera pas comme ça qu'il faut que
tu le vois le dit exactement
effectivement il faut chaud quand tu
peux partager justement les bonnes
pratiques du québec jacques sauf
qu'elles puissent avoir le rayonnement
que mérite un partout à travers le monde
sinon c'est tellement souvent référence
aux pays scandinaves par exemple c'est
la finlande la norvège la suède pour
toutes sortes de choses mais on oublie
souvent que ces pays le sont un peu plus
grandes comme le québec en terme de
population
en fait on discute beaucoup beaucoup
plus d'hommes que kelly pays scandinaves
mais t on a toujours tendance on dirait
parfois à diminuer pas de captiver qu'on
est trop bas au contraire l'est du pays
juriste de façon extraordinaire commis
quinze conteneurs qui risque d'avoir une
influence positive et mesurable sur le
réseau au pays dimanche
moi je suis convaincu qu'elle québec ait
un pays scandinave en amérique du nord
puis avoir justement cette influence
n'est même montant qu'en donnent les
moyens de l'avoir choisi sur les bateaux
nous tentons par les petits en ce moment
il ya une espèce d'uniformisation de
montcy avec la culture américaine tu
prend énormément de place que
l'affirmation ça viendrait une instance
que c'est tellement important de
promouvoir les différents bagages
culturels à travers le monde et c'est ce
qui fait la richesse et la beauté
notamment sur ceux qu'on aime voyager
que l'on est frustré imprudent d'en être
privée avec avec l'accis convient
actuellement il faut aussi l'aider à 10
puis c'est le fait qu' on soigne fera
une société francophone en amérique est
pas rien non plus tout ça va nous
apporter plusieurs davantage comme en ce
moment où vous économique via l'afrique
est en pleine expansion mais en
astiquant énormément pays francophones
donc pour réaliser que d'être un pays
francophone en amérique du nord
ça nous donnerait un avantage
stratégique important quand vient le
temps de faire des affaires par exemple
avec classique qui doit faire en sorte
que nos entreprises québécoises puissent
puissent profiter justement qu'on puisse
avoir des échanges avec ces nouveaux
marchés
je trouve ça intéressant aussi cabaret
cuba parce que souvent justement le
souverainisme ou les fêtes vouloir
devenir un pays c'est déjà perçu comme
un repli sur soi ou comme un pied
je m'en veux on veut conserver nos
affaires mais tandis que c'est
complètement l'inversé si le contrat de
repli sur soi si vous ne permettre de
mieux rayonner à l'international qui de
mieux aussi avoir une influence positive
vraiment c'est pire quand quelqu'un on
parle de des différentes cultures au
québec comment qu'on pourrait embrasser
cette diversité culturelle là est ce que
tu crois que il ya une espèce de saint
d'âge dans le mouvement souverainiste
avec déjà de la plus vieille école un
petit peu qui eux j'imagine sans dire
sans lancer les mots racistes dans les
armées qui sont beaucoup plus axé sur
rester le peuple québécois blancs
francophones puis je demande c'est
fermer les frontières mais je crois
qu'il serait peut-être motivé par une
espèce de déception que ces gens là on y
est
je m'explique c'est ma maison ça fait
dix ans à peu près que je m'implique au
sein du mouvement souverainiste mais
j'ai rencontré tellement de gens qui
sont là depuis des années
jamais depuis les tout débuts dans les
années 60 par exemple puis champion
essayer justement dans l'avenue élitisme
qui ont vu certains politiciens de
l'époque essayait de faire des liens
avec des communautés différentes
j'aime ça n'avait pas fonctionné à
l'époque j'ai l'impression que plusieurs
souvenirs de longue date sont un peu
déçus peut-être désillusionnés
par les résultats que le mouvement a pu
avoir dans les pensées première vague
j'ai l'impression que les choses ont
changé depuis ce temps là que des
conneries qu'on doit se résigner
cette offre était plus difficile de
convaincre quelqu'un qui vient d'arriver
au québec et d'y construire ses clients
processus d'immigration dans le
gouvernement du canada qui cette
personne même avoir un attachement
nécessairement envers les canadiens qui
l'a accueilli donc déjà en partant ça va
prendre plus de temps à peut-être
établir un dialogue avec la personne sur
la question de l'indépendance du québec
mais maintenant il faut qu'on le prenne
ce temps là que le phénomène j'ai
l'impression qui est ailleurs c'est que
beaucoup de gens qui pensent des gens
plus âgés surtout au sein du mouvement
que je pense pas que c'est quelque chose
que je la rends je leur en veux pas
nécessairement parce que je pense qu'ils
se sont dans ce que ça vaut pas la peine
puis je pense que la nouvelle génération
je demande dans le mouvement doit au
contraire la preuve je sais pas je suis
convaincu que c'est positif parce que
j'étudie beaucoup qu'est ce qui se passe
en écosse notamment
j'en ai consulté un mouvement
souverainiste et fort qu'ils ont réussi
dans les dernières années à convaincre
une grande partie est un niveau des
costes et à adhérer au projet
d'indépendance
parce qu'ils ont vraiment réussi à
rétablir des liens de confiance c'est si
on est souvent l'image au québec comme
quoi c'est juste les libéraux qui sont
moins contents liens avec les
communautés immigrantes dans un sens
c'est aussi faux que mj parle avec
beaucoup de leaders de communautés à
vauréal amis qui m'ont dit que c'était
juste à peu près les libéraux qui allait
alors d'événements ou qu'ils
entretenaient des liens de confiance
avec ces personnes ne va je pensais qu
on a un projet politique
ça devrait être la base la confiance et
le dialogue
enfin avant d'aller devant le projet
politique comme les dépendances il faut
que je puisse avoir une base de
confiance avec toi ces cintres appareils
accroc pretty fait dans les dernières
années au sein du mouvement
souverainiste
parce que moi je pense qu'il ya une
belle réactivité de la part des gens de
toutes les origines au projet
d'indépendance
mais encore faut-il qu'on fasse le lien
qu'on les fasse sentir partie prenante
du projet autant que les gens qui sont
ici au québec
il faut aussi tirer un avantage concret
pour eux il faut qu'on leur faut qu'on
leur donne les arguments de dire qu'il
est complètement ça va vous apporter ici
ou si c'est parce que si juste juste
faire dire mais le québec c'est beaupuy
félix éclat et qui écrit des beaux
textes c'est pas assez pour que quelqu
un jour lendemain veulent faire un pays
il faut vraiment que je pense quelque
chose de très tangible est dans le nom
c'est clamait de justes tant de l'armée
comme ça qui ne montrer que le pays
il sera pas construit juste après kim
est quoi deux touches françaises mais
qui est aussi une invitation à
participer à cette construction lettre
c'est quand même pas rien
de façon à être un pays libre pas que je
pense justement si tout le monde pouvait
chanter porte il devait dire qu'ils ont
un rôle à jouer dans cette démarche
déjà on aurait vraiment avancer je peux
je pense aussi pour venir sur le point d
des vieux souverainistes sont vus des
souvenirs de première la première
génération sont veux si je pense que il
ya un besoin de réactualiser puis de
questionner les motifs derrière ce parce
que ces souverainistes le ont la mémoire
d'un peuple québécois qui qui opprime et
et qui est qui et qui n'eut qu'une
minorité qui est que peut être plus de
moyens et plus de ressources qu'il ait
pris la majorité parce que ceux qui
avaient le pouvoir la richesse des plus
les anglophones certaine époque au
québec puis c'est plus haut le jeu donne
des peuples quand même qui qui qui
s'épanouit qui va bien qui est beau dit
fac c'est plus cette même dynamique lol
on n'est plus le c'est la raison pour
laquelle on fait de l'indépendance et
pas de s'affranchir b s'affirmer parce
qu'on le fait déjà
en fait les jeunes ce nom on comptera
comme se dit maintenant c'est plus que
ce l'était bien qu'on ait déjà ton
rayonne déjà mais je pense que c'est
juste de d'aller plus loin encore pour
ça que moi j'aime beaucoup le mot
ambitions quand par l'indépendance parce
que c'est juste
voir avoir tous les outils pour
atteindre notre plein potentiel social
il déjà bien mais on pourrait en faire
encore mieux aller encore plus loin
c'est ça la force et c'est juste un
autre point aussi qu'un qu'on compense
un des types par exemple reprenons
l'exemple de lakovic 19 ans m'a menti ou
est ce que on si on se compare aux
autres endroits dans le monde on fait ça
les meilleurs c'est au monde
mais en ce moment ce que ces acides se
dire si tu es ce que c'est assez de se
dire on est les meilleurs au monde où
est-ce qu'il faut se comparer à ce qu'on
pourrait arrêter
je pense que dans le cas d'un que de la
question de départ anticipant ce que
c'est c'est capital c'est pas tout ça
mais là c'est correct on est correct si
on se compare on est bien ici le tuer
mais c'est du roi mais comparé toi pas
au reste du monde comparé toi qu'est ce
que ça pourrait être puis c'est là que
c'est là justement pour faire le pont
entre les deux points de dire ça prend
du concret pour être capable d'imaginer
ce surtout pour des gens comme ça qui
arrive ici que c'est déjà mille fois
mieux que dans leur pays natal 10 et
déjà comme ils y arrivent ici c'est le
rêve canadien de cesser ses supers
l'appui je suis d'accord j'habite ici je
trouve ça super vivent au québec tu sais
sauf que sauf que justement d'avoir du
concret pouvoir dire et se situe trouve
ça super imagine comment ça pourrait
l'être encore plus et puis c'est là que
ces deux des loges les pressions
viennent se rejoignent puis de l'espèce
de d'appartenance mixé avec avec du
concret qui fait que qui fait un
argument est extrêmement pesant je
trouve totalement changeons un petit peu
de sujets en ce moment on est
on est dans une situation où est ce que
je change mon sujet pas tant que ça mais
où est ce qu on se retourne beaucoup
vert dans les dernières la dernière
semaine peut-être le whisky un espèce de
mouvement de consommons locale qui j'ai
l'impression que ceux ci cette idée là
réussi à survivre à l'aco vite 19
c'est un pas majeur pour le québec en
général
qu'est-ce qui est qui sont selon toi les
les
les prochaines étapes dans un dans une
économie qui renel à partir du
consommation locale à partir du québec
comment qu'on relance le québec une fois
que ceux-ci c'est possible déclaré la
chef salle c'est tellement fondamentale
si on réalise pas à quel point nos choix
comme consommateur donc des
répercussions sur notre économie c'est
sûr les gens qui ont des entreprises et
le fait s'il ya vraiment un mouvement
non seulement 10 à l'heure actuelle
parce qu'on en voit déjà les effets à
l'eau ce matin je sais que les
producteurs maraîchers donc nos
agriculteurs reçoivent énormément de
demandes pour des légumes fait baptiser
c'est tellement une bonne nouvelle qu'on
fasse ça vient d'arriver le sais quoi
c'est ce que m'a envoyée terrain
augmenté depuis quelques années ils ont
trait à voir on a plusieurs jours c'est
vraiment le premier ministre qui lance
cet appel le son devient chaque sac et
comme j'ai fait des affaires à la scène
bastille tellement de gens qui écoutent
les pointes trail de tout de suite les
gens réagissent que ce soit pour héma
québec que ce soit pour le bénévolat
à chaque fois les sites web ont
carrément explosé
c'est la même chose pour lui n'est pas
ni bhl j'ai pas eu vraiment que tu as
plus de poursuivre son besoin les
entrepreneurs qui détient une
augmentation des réservations en ligne
pour les gens qui ont pu déjà voir des
boutiques pour leur commerce
c'est une bonne nouvelle ça veut d'abord
parce des personnages d'abord et avant
tout la relance économique du québec
tient pour que ça aille mieux si on peut
compter sur nous
c'est quoi les autres pays qui vont
faire en sorte que notre économie va
être lancé je pense que c'est vraiment
nos choix comme consommateur on parle
des entrepreneurs oui mais aussi nos
artistes en ce moment c'est qu'ils vont
nécessairement avec l'annulation de tous
les spectacles
ça sera pas facile pour eux dans les
semaines à venir et puis j'ai vu des
initiatives lancées comme la lecture blu
musique bleus pour encourager les gens à
acheter de la musique de nos créateurs
il va falloir que ça perdure dans le
temps qui passe que y'aura pas les
gouvernements vont auront beau injecter
tout l'argent de l'argent qu'ils veulent
mais si on suit pas comme consommateur
sans réussir à repartir dès qu'on parle
également de toutes les restaurateurs
ayant ne pas être de 25 à 30 ans ont
menacé de fermer actuellement partie du
tout le monde dans les mois à venir on
s'engage également à riz encouragé ses
co mexique le aller au restaurant pour
ce qu'ils peuvent évidemment acheter les
cartes cadeaux tout faire en sorte que
l'économie d'ici rôle mais je pense que
tu as veut montrer que c'est une basse
et l'oeil capable de perdurer au delà de
la crise ça veut sans aucun doute à
cause des sports pour la n'est pas juste
pour l'économie ça joue bien jouer
tellement un grand rôle pour les défis
environnementaux par exemple des leviers
de commande et tout le temps des choses
qui sont faites à l'extérieur tu doivent
passer par plusieurs pays tu dois en
avion ou pire traversée tour du
conteneur sur des bateaux j'ai tellement
une empreinte écologique qui forte à
notre façon de consommer en ce moment
que juste le fait de pouvoir ramener au
moins une partie mais ce qu'on consomme
au québec même si ce n'est pas un
instrument produit tu fait à 100% au
tibet ben déjà fait à 50% ici est la
différence
élite énorme mais encore une fois c'est
comment parler ton doux pour les
déplacements si on faisait seulement
comme celui je n'ai pas 20 % de plus
québécois on diminuerait encore une fois
de façon très importante les gaz à effet
de serre qu'on produit au quotidien
j'ai vraiment l'impression justement que
les achats en ligne senna de la guerre
parce que c'est c'est de plus en plus la
façon normale seulement de consommer
maintenant
justement il ya ph ou par les deux
entrepreneurs qui sont honnêtement on
n'a pas loupé la femme à 10 et sur cinq
dollars investis en ligne mais mis en
ligne sur des achats par les québécois y
en a quatre sur cinq qui sortent du pays
qui vont aux états unis le produit
nantis donc c'est quand même aberrant
comment penser à ce que j'ai l'internet
c'est comme s'ils s'inspirent est
justement les ressources du québec pour
les les injecter dans des
multinationales que dans des grandes
compagnies américaines certainement
berardi justement parce que les
entrepreneurs le yoyo un peu annoncé un
genre de plateforme un peu compétitive
au panier bleus mais ce que je qui à mon
sens une bonne chose qu'à une saine
compétition de plateforme et il alla
plus la plus à point pour la plus
usuelle fric au monde y gagnera mais
justement c'est le cellphone sacré ce
puits mauger l'impression c'est des
bonnes habitudes qui vont rester mais
justement la crise en même temps d'un
côté nous fait voir qu'est ce qui bouge
tellement de la société quebecor nos
bons coups mais ça ne fait aussi d'y
réaliser des genres d'opérations comme
ce tir qui existent qu'on fait
qu'énoncer ça peut pas être considérée
comme ceux qui seraient contents quand
un autre exemple en fait justement tu es
exemple les salaires de certains
employés essentiels comme les
politiciens c'est comme ça prenait ça
pour qu'on se rende compte que ça
absolument aucun sens les salaires qui
font tilt qui comme aux autres mais
c'est pas un job facile maintenant mais
ça jamais été une job ça toujours été
sous payé puisque comme au québec le les
yeux sont tournés là dessus on se rend
compte qu'il faut que ça change
aujourd'hui le court avec un prêche pas
quand on prend un point de presse
justement le dit qu'il fallait que ça
change c'est non je pense qu'elle est
maman crise comme ça mais la lumière des
éléments de la société compte
ce qui est peut être moins dans deux
quotidiens puis on dirait que l'urgence
la situation j'écris aussi une réponse
beaucoup plus rapide que ce qu'on aurait
une heure dans la vie normale on veut
c'est par exemple il est préposé aux
bénéficiaires ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'on dit au québec qui sont
pas des payes et qu'on en a besoin plus
que par exemple du manque de personnel
mettez andré qu'on répétition répète ce
à travers les mois les années touche
n'ya pas grand-chose chambre haute
il ya une crise comme celle ci tu viens
vraiment montrer à quel point ça va mal
finir vraiment la lumière là dessus
qu'il attendrait que ça va influencer
des changements beaucoup plus rapide
qu'est ce qui avait pu cette crise c'est
la même chose pour pour lâcher le
terrain comme vous a tantôt avait été
achetée il ya de l'engouement on le voit
naître plusieurs lignes ont créé une
accélération phénoménale qui tant mieux
si moi je me dis si on peut et sait
capter les éléments de costumes dans la
crise négative conduit en ce moment mais
on va nous ressortir plus forts comme
ceci jusqu'à ce que florence l'ont très
vite mis en ligne type s'était tu es
comme des parents justement qui sont
alors à la maison car enfants qui sont
comme eux je paraphrase le métier on
prenait cholet notre enfant passé qui
était parfait pour prenez toujours sa
défense en allemand avec les professeurs
mais monsieur madame le professeur sexy
parce que j'étais à la maison tout le
temps on se rend compte du travail que
si et du qu'ils puissent occuper nos
enfants à la journée d'action se
réaliser comme traînée beaucoup de
choses pour rater ma mort exactement
mais vraiment une autre affaire aussi
j'ai l'impression est ce que vous
entendez suffit juste de musique toi
quoi ça que parfait excellent un autre
enfant qui qui va probablement changer
pillages et excitait avec yannick de
martino parce qu'on écoute le même la
même émission en ce moment puis on
trouve sur le rôle mais je demandais de
sétois quesque de quoi ça a l'air si ton
temps
or rapprocher t puis à lui me disais bon
je viens de juin d'acheter une maison
puis le du gpu ou viens d'acheter je
passe est une maison mais peu importe
j'ai plus de chômage et plus de revenu
j'ai pu aucune façon de savoir combien
je vais pouvoir faire est-ce que je vais
refaire comme je faisais avant ou non ti
pied cet accord ne continue à parler un
petit peu mais je me suis dit en ce
moment les gens réalisent réellement ce
qui leur manque le plus c'est moins ce
qui manque c'est pas d'aller dans un
centre d'achats achetés aux hlm des tee
shirts mois se masse qui manque le plus
c'est d'aller dans un bon resto d'aller
voir un spectacle puis de juste d'avoir
des expériences culturelles
ici c'est ce qui manque c'est pas la
consommation ce qui manque c'est pas si
la falaise qui manque c'est vraiment
l'expérience humaine
je crois que les gens vont sûrement se
rendre compte de ce hub puis une autre
conversation en conclut en disant j'ai
l'impression que c'est ça qui volent
start et c'est le plus vite l'impression
qu'on va pouvoir dire à kengo le monde
vont paraître sur quoi je me suis
vraiment ennuyer d'aller voir en
spectacle je suis vraiment nui et
d'aller voir un show d'humour je suis
vraiment nui d'aliments chances de
rester remplissage et là vraiment ça va
donner un bon petit cool j'ai
l'impression que les gens les l'argent
qu'ils vont avoir des supplémentaires
pour pour deux dans leur vie va aller
dans ces choses le ses classes à
intervenir à l'essentiel je pense qu'on
va être plus prendre cet argent c'est
dans ce convoi qui fait une différence
c'est justement en train d'acheter un
tee shirt au h&m ou d'encourager je
t'avais un artiste de passer du temps
avec les personnes combien autour d'un
bon buteur
je pense qu'on va plus réaliser la
valeur d exemple je le dis ici je pense
que c'est qu'est ce qui manque à
beaucoup de gens c'est de voir
physiquement les gens qu'on aime le 11
févier ont fait des super des cinq à
cette somme si on fait tout ce avec nos
amis avec nos proches nos familles mais
qu'est ce qu'on va enfin pouvoir les
prendre dans nos bras
les voies pour vrai je pense qu'on va
aussi l'apprécier deux fois plus ce type
qui veut dire à papa dans sa résidence
que tu as les publicités trop souvent le
fait pour pouvoir aller les visiter pour
être exact arrêter d'y aller qu'as tu
pouvais type sont à calais après aussi
s'éclater en parle beaucoup mais c'est
ainsi qu'avant personnes âgées une idée
aussi les allemands avec dsk l'actrice a
même créé a indiqué mme alençon c'est
plus difficile puis à quel point c'était
important de trouver des façons de
technologies ou à d'autres moyens de
briser cet isolement lui ou de chez rien
entre nous quelle on avait quoi on
n'avait pas pensé auparavant c'était
quelque chose de bien ce qui va
ressortir de piste hier à pâques ma
soeur fait une cabane à sucre dans sa
cour ou est ce que ma mère est allée ma
famille habite au québec marc italie ce
parc est avec son charme au bout de la
rue puis le sont venus à pied plein été
quand même distance d'à peu près 10 m
plus nous ont appelés les autres membres
de la famille sont pas québec une somme
issue room blanc faisait comme #microvk
chez nous et à mon appart à montréal
plomb faisait une jarre de cabane à
sucre pour pâques
par zoom soit effectivement c'est le
genre d'affaires que tu prend pour
acquis mais que tu réalises pas jusqu'à
dire que tu l'as vu le taux débiteur mes
excuses non c'est bon c'est fait un
super justement samedi soir de parts et
puis ma mère fait livrer deux sens pas
chez tout le monde dit finalement on a
passé deux ans à régner sur zone
hmm hmm bas vraie vie on pense pas
désirable mon père après 45 minutes il
monta au pivot ce que je dis mais quand
même on dirait que le fait de jeter la
difficulté nous nous arrange pas mal
apprécié plus plomb
jordi pendant deux heures et demie ce
qu'on faisait jamais quand même drôle
non c'est vrai on dit qu'on a encore
plus besoin de contacts exactes sur un
point de vue de de carrière
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce
qui est dans ton futur qu'est-ce qui est
dans tes cartes qu'est-ce qui est dans
tes dents des objectifs dans pays
lorsque tu veux faire mal en question et
moi c'est sûr qu'ils aient depuis un an
ma vie est quand même mais rapidement
changé comme déguster parce que je suis
maintenant indépendant à l'assemblée
nationale souverainistes indépendants
sans le trouver mais dans mon quotidien
le député en fait constituée auprès des
citoyens à changer un jour et que sa
chance plus dans le travail
parlementaire c'est moi qui prends avec
moi
les initiatives de ce que je fais j'ai
pas de ligne de parti à ses facéties
suspens intéressante et ça m'amène
beaucoup à réfléchir justement sur la
place de la part d'amis en politique
c'est le statu quo en ce moment on en
voit peu c'est bien parce que dans le
moment de la crise au directement mais
soudés ensemble qui les gens travaillent
dans l'intérêt est plus grande et
québécois peu importe nos différences
mais la crise c'est un fait d état
devrait toujours comme ça c'est mon
principe pas de dire je ne devrais pas
avoir de positons gouvernement elle peut
poser des questions au contraire mais il
ya une façon de faire qui est en ce
moment depuis le début justement de tout
ce qui se passe avec le canard diffuse
les députés au lieu de faire un espèce
de chaux pour tenter de descendre le
gouvernement à chaque fois qu'ils aient
quelque chose qui se passe - james bond
l'est mais je trouve que les gens sont
beaucoup plus constructif maintenant
c'est intéressant qui comme moi j'ai
l'impression qu'à vérité que ça devrait
être beaucoup plus comme ça ça devrait
être plus respectueux et ça devrait être
plus constructif et fier de voir ces
différences non seulement mon expérience
comme député indépendant mais le de voir
comment l'ensemble des députés agissent
depuis le début de la crise ça me fait
beaucoup réfléchir je mens sur le futur
ii
de nos institutions de nos parlements
moi je sais quel est mon avenir
personnel à moitié fournie commun comme
député je sais qu noter les prochaines
élections sont morts un bon petit bout
encore deux ans deux ans et demi est ce
que j'aimerais présenter ou pas je vais
jouer mais je trouve que de ma position
mon objectif c'est de contribuer
justement à cette réflexion le sur notre
système politique
2 1 qui de 2,2 dans un amendement mon
objectif politique c'est une dame ans on
en devient par les tentes ou à
l'indépendance québec géant de voir si
tous les effets consent en ce moment
vont poursuivre m
moi j avais quelques collaborateurs on a
envie une organisation puis en fait on
devait lancer nos activités le mode
masse avec un conseil d'administration
tout seul on est un peu de rouge se
repose mais comme est comme le reste du
québec
mais on risque fort justement des grands
comptes est pas très impatient car on
change de maillot en gare de noël nous
ayons les verts ce pour quoi et quand
les activités vont reprendre de plus
belle
dossiers créés allait justement qui
résume un peu ta pensée et puis ton
cheminement puis aussi les étapes amené
sa peu justement ambitions québec que
j'ai lu voilà qui met deux questions par
avoir c est ce que est ce que depuis
qu'ils étaient indépendantes
s'inquiétait plus de poids plus
d'influencé à l'assemblée nationale puis
dans ton travail ou l' inverse puis
deuxième question est ce que est ce que
tu penses que les modèles politiques
comment qui comme un kit organise un
rassemblement qui fonctionnent avec des
partis qui ont une pensée assez unique
il faut pas trop déranger justement de
la ligne qui sait ce qu'est cette
organisation le communqué comment qui
est commun qui est fait et vous prenez
les problématiques puis comment comment
on peut la changer ce serait qu'on est
un bon modèle de politique des
démocraties déjà commencé par vendre le
bien en question parce que je trouve ça
vraiment fondamental si je commence à
fond
scène en ce moment à l'assemblée
nationale fut nommé parlement de
sociétés occidentales en général c'est
un parti au pouvoir fait au gouvernement
toutes les oppositions qui le jeu des
oppositions c'est toujours de faire mal
paraître le gouvernement pour
l'opposition pour qu'elle pousse on
puisse mieux paraître comme gagner des
points politiques qui espérait qu aux
prochaines élections on reste aux
gagnants disent jamais al'avantage de
participants de position de diriger le
gouvernement indien c'est parce que plus
une opinion publique change qui est
intacte hiver par exemple du
gouvernement bien plus qu'elle passe de
plus on a des chances d'avoir le pouvoir
aux prochaines élections et que c'est
une logique super mal stern parce que ça
amène à ce que par exemple quand
gouvernement présente j'ai pas un projet
de loi ou soumet une idée bathium
députés dans l'opposition c'est une
blonde peu de temps les gens qui sont là
parce que c'est le système qui fait
demain sincèrement mon style et j'ai
déjà joué dans ses bras quand je t aime
quand j'étais au parti québécois contre
un moule dans lequel tu es obligé de
d'être conforme et sont même un style
différents degrés et met donc obligé
d'évoquer mal aussi
si le gouvernement propose de la faire
toi ton rôle de trouver un peu la
feuille qui annonce que le gouvernement
propose plein d'essayer de grosses et
tenter d'attirer l'attention des médias
qui est de faire en sorte que ce soit
perçu comme très très grave
alors que parfois d'être moins grasse
km/h qu'on veut donner l'idée serait
aussi positive de faire changer par
exemple à l'issue d'un gouvernement avec
une approche différente
c'est en allant voir le ministre est
vraiment au travail en commission
parlementaire pour améliorer les choses
dont ils comptent toujours obligé de
faire un show avec ses mais
malheureusement c'est souvent ce sont
les partis parce que pour capter
l'attention des médias qu'une cité pour
course de conditionner plus
favorablement pour les prochaines
élections
j'ai aussi quelque chose de néfaste
quand on veut toujours cherché comme
parti politique à être élu ou réélu aux
prochaines élections c'est qu'on est
très peu porté à penser à long terme en
parce que tu veux toujours réussir à
voir le meilleur résultat possible pour
- parce que nos cycles électoraux dure
quatre ans qui a pendant plus de limite
dans les mandats facteur est il du
gouvernement ou même un député qui lui
est sans arrêt des petits qui sont le 30
40 ans parfois parfois moins bien sûr
mais je ne le peux je connais ici pax
east tant que ça à penser au long terme
en tête souvent négatives pour les
parties parce que c'est encore une fois
je reviens à la crise actuelle méthode
du gouvernement qui investit beaucoup
pour du matériel médical
mais les stars écouter shine qui ont des
rues moins d'argent pour d'autres choses
là les gens se seraient dit mais
pourquoi tu investis dans le matériel
médical alors que y'a pas de crise m
mais au final aujourd'hui on en manque
donc cette espèce de manque de prise
lisibilité à ce que tu veux à investir
l'argent que tu portais ya eu des crises
d'hulster maintenant parce que les gens
du temple pour que tu peux gagner des
points politiques pour la prochaine
élection et la constance du poste ait vu
comme comme changement mais je trouve
que il faut qu'on prétend ce les
systèmes politiques cause justement de
ces deux choses qui montrent qu'ils me
sont apparus quelqu'un tu peux tu parler
la première c'est juste cette dedans
dans ce que tu viens de dire si on fait
juste reculé un petit peu avec la
fameuse d'austérité du gouvernement de
philippe couillard qui a été qu'ils
étaient critiquées vraiment grandement
puis la minute que le gouvernement de la
cac prend le pouvoir le caecum et on
voit si nos budgets puis on a bien trop
d'argent j'arrête le puits tout le monde
fait comme à la cac
ils ont de l'argent d'un coffre mois
mais cet argent là les allées étaient
accumulés au détriment du parti libéral
c'est parce que c'était leur argent fait
gradient pris une décision populaire qui
peut-être je suis pas si ce qui aurait
coûté l'élection sûrement pas juste mais
une décision populaire qui bénéficie au
gouvernement qui vient après mais ça ça
arrive
oh ça arrive pas dans le système qu'on a
actuellement
pis si somme toute honorable d'avoir
d'avoir pris une décision impopulaire
qui bénéficie au québec c'est fait pour
toutes les blondes qu'on peut porter au
parti libéral du québec
ce n'est pas mon habitude d'avoir pris
un coup pour la sueur des choses qui en
fait différemment sans aucun doute
ouais mais tout à fait en fait le parti
libéral se sont fait prendre à leur
propre jeu avec le spectre parce que
leur stratégie est recoupée beaucoup en
deux ans puis ensuite investi énormément
les deux années suivantes
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait mais non on
oublie un peu les deux dernières années
rien j'écoute les maisons ils se sont
fait ce sont peut-être prendre à leur
propre jeu qui était aussi comme un
titre et des élus ainsi pour lui il y
avait le bourget de couper en deux ans
à la fin on veut donner du tableau
électoraux dans un studio à meilhan
investi un peu partout en vigueur
pendant les élections confiance à leur
permettrait de gagner après ce
allotements de simply red et investir
dans une épicerie pas plus que ce sont
15 à la maison d'épicerie qu'il ya des
solutions faciles pour se sortir de cet
attentat que ce modèle est pas mal le
modèle qui a partout et ce dans les
sociétés occidentales en général mais
j'ai je pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
diminue c'est surtout ce phénomène de la
ligne 2 si je pense qu'il faut qu'on
redonne plus d'indépendance aux députés
qui est il ya des endroits novembre
fonctionne de façon totalement
différente au nôtre est en tout je
parlais des pays scandinaves la finlande
si souvent des coalitions justement qui
vont gouverner le pays
artiste est née il ya moins de
gouvernement majoritaire et président
alliances entre indifférente à steve et
dans le gouvernement les gens de
plusieurs styles différents
ce dont je parle à feu longues mais
c'est comme ça plusieurs pays européens
ça existe et c'est intéressant et ce nom
il yad'autres ma mère m'a dit si on
tiendra son rang
les histoires du nord ouest où un
gouvernement qu on appelle un
gouvernement de consensus fait la beille
votre parti il en a qui lui les députés
sont élus dans leurs circonscriptions
selon programme qui propose pour les
gens de leur compte et j'ai une fois que
tous les députés sont élus
entre eux ils vont voter un dirigeant
gouvernement puis les ministres factiva
fonctionne vraiment partout la boration
j'adorais matin ça devrait être au tibet
mais je pense que beaucoup de modèles et
l on peut certainement c'est ce cri
provoquant un meilleur j'aime beaucoup
l'idée de que tu que tu lances idée tu
fait qu' il n'y a pas de limite aux
mandats tu peux avoir en tant que député
ça c'est sûr que ça a pris un ris pas la
mise de l'avant du futur le dessus mais
ça serait une bonne option je trouve que
c'est super intéressant est ce que tu
emmènes comme point de dire hey hey vous
avez j'avais un moment de fête le mieux
pour le québec du rendement de l'autre
et c'est bien parce que toute façon peu
pour leur bravoure tafer à la limite
d'un c'est aux états unis et la
présidence une limite de deux mandats
mais c'est pas le cas pour elle pour les
députés même sens que celle de l'analyse
est ce que tu après avoir une influence
positive je me dis un magnifique ont été
dépités après ces dix ou douze ans il
semble que tu peux pas être passé l'a
peut-être internet avait un projet
réalisé mais de contribuer et puis un
moment donné de sa forte renouvellement
puisque sa force les gens à penser à à
plus long terme parce que de toute
manière il n'y avait pas possibilité
d'être constamment réélu c'est super
intéressant vraiment une passion on on
pense toujours que les hommes si comme
son père ni rechange j'étais j'ai
l'impression qu'on combat souvent libre
en baisse et le match et ça marche
pierre et apprennent par exemple dans la
crise actuelle j'entends souvent les
commentateurs dire à berlin steffen ton
va beaucoup de collaborations aux
députés en fait partie mais après ce
sommet à savoir tourner comme à nantes
correct comme ça que ça fonctionne mais
je crois qu'ils en vivent beaucoup et on
pense que c'est comme ça que ça marche
c'est comme ça me fait rien changé en
vrai que je
je refuse de penser qu'on puisse pas
avoir du changement ça c'est l'idéalisme
de la jeunesse s'est attaqué à 50 ça
sera temps de faire comme la bad fait
que le mode désabusé mais sinon c'est
toi toi ton rêve de fallait des parts
dans ce lieu dit clairement
quoi qu on passe québécois pour pour le
véhicule de ce projet love c'est pour ça
que tu le quittes et justement j'ai
l'impression que tu rêves de l'espèce
des collaborations de coalition entre
les souverainistes de tous les partis
que ça soit du pq dqs même la cac qui a
énormément tirer mais comment commence a
pu s'organiser
comment ça peut se manifester
concrètement est ce que ça serait pareil
nouveau parti politique ça serait
quelque chose qui transcende ce je pense
que ça va devoir passer par fax au titre
en son sein
je pense vont ils encore le parti quoi
j'étais mais il existe toujours il ya
des jambes c'est les gens qui croisent
crois c'est que moi je ne me sentais pas
avec moi de continuer comme ça
d'autres souverainistes mpf jacques ritt
eu beaucoup le travail de leur vie je
suis permis de voir que dans le
mouvement malheureusement voient
toujours comme étant des compétiteurs et
encore une fois différemment ou femmes
politiques et électoraux qui je pense
que comme souverainiste
ces deux sticks le lac on doit se porter
j'ai l'impression que tu a repensé par
quelque chose qui transcende justement
les partis qui veut c'est moi je veux un
peu comme l'est celle de coalition
éventuellement aux instances électorales
qui pourrait un nombre en hausse donc de
fusionner les pics upi tuer ce parti je
pense que c'est une avenue qui est
possible c'est à dire un but et essayer
avec des alliances électorales
mais il ya des gentils et ristournes
east voix pendant dans têtu qui se voit
pas nous tuer à la limite tu sois pas
dans la caq non plus si jamais on vient
d'être cotées comme com
toi de toute évidence ouais non c'est
exactement
mettez moi mon objectif c'est que ça
fonctionne quiz marché est déjà une
organisation qui existe quand même les
organes façon unie pour l'indépendance
dès les huitièmes est qu on la
concertation entre les partis politiques
mais personnellement je n'ai aucune
confiance dans les partis politiques
pourraient nous amener à cette espèce de
couach dont les parquets depuis qqs
comme je faisais une ombre 10 gt
s'entendre ça peut fonctionner pourquoi
ça peut fonctionner si beaucoup parce
que les partis priorise leur intérêt à
ce qu'ils veulent faire le meilleur
score aux élections factices compte
apporter à ceux d un ou de se partager
les québec son voeu partagé des
circonscriptions mais non ils pensent
qu'à eux mêmes tous ces aliments est
capable de faire le meilleur résultat
possible
est ce qu'ils pensent que ça que moi ce
que je pense que ça va d'abord partir de
la base si beaucoup de souverainistes au
québec et beaucoup de gens qui sont
engagés pour cette idée là mais je pense
que c'est eux qui doivent mettre la
pression sur les partis et non pas
attendre que les partis eux-mêmes
finissent par se bouger c'est que ce
soit en mettant de la présidence du
parti ou en créant justement l espace
politique pour qu'il puisse y avoir ce
genre de coalition l'extincteur
je pense que c'est le seul moyen d'y
arriver ça va peut-être prendre plus de
temps mais je pense que si on restait
les anciennes méthodes qui ont
fonctionné on va au même résultat
je serais curieux de savoir la
proportion des députés qui sont
souverainistes la menace est là parce
que j'ai l'impression que ça doit être
un gros chiffre même peut-être même
majorité le jeu paraîtra mon chapeau
mais ce conte les piqûres touly
j'imagine tous les députés du pq sont
souverainistes à q est-ce une bonne
proportion puis à la caq une bonne
proportion aussi finalement si tous ces
gens le voter demain matin matin sur sur
un projet de loi ou sur un idée de
référendum de quoi que ce soit par
rapport à la dépendance puis que les
gens je vais pas nécessairement la ligne
de parti mais voter avec leur corps il y
aurait des choses qui penseraient c est
tellement énorme
c'est vrai je convaincu que oui parce
que je suis convaincu que la majorité
des députés de la ta
oups
ça
il ya plein de gens qui les banques sont
en politique pour d'autres raisons mais
qui ont sont deux sont pas du tout
contre cette idée là et même j'ai déjà
eu des dix ont un compte ici avec
certains députés genre demandé tu avais
un petit en faveur de l'indépendance ça
va voter oui ou non cette batterie qui
souvent séquence de ses députés dans
décembre et ont dû bien vite et je veux
dire oui mais je ne serai pas pour ça
mais je veux être et oui oui j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme ça pour
beaucoup de québécois on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il ya pu tant la peur
autour de l'indépendance
si les gens sont moins ça vous remet un
contre c'est juste un peu de temps pour
non plus personnellement c'est avec
raison que le plus de fils pour le
mouvement ça va être arrivé à assen non
vraiment fait ce qu'on veut se reposer
la question
collectivement la question se repose la
question très très confiante mac ont
gagné de comptage et de marges explique
québécois la maintenance il peut
difficilement essayer de se rendre à ce
moment là ouais c'est ça ce serait la
question c'est un match ensemble
comme un symbole ce que les gens ont
juste parlé avec avait un oui ou un non
si les plus secrets comme d'un musicien
l'amateur tourne à l'assemblée nationale
françois legault d'un mot d'ordre était
même toi même tu passes en ligne de
parti mais je m'égare non pas enclenché
cette démarche là bas c'est sûr qu'on
ait la majorité
si je suis pas mal convaincu de notre
côté du pcc s'est un peu c'est optimiste
je me serais jamais j'aime danser comme
s'appuyer encore une fois pour faire un
cercle complet avec le début la
discussion j'ai de mon village à m
pierre qu'intentionnel québécois j'ai
vraiment l'impression de beaucoup
personnes qui nous écoutent en ce moment
merci infiniment nous avons encore des
dons temps même et c'est à vous de
gamins c'est le super discussion où
est-ce qu'on peut te suit le magic
sur les réseaux sociaux en france très
actifs sur facebook presse palma même si
j'ai vue d'imposer les tarnaises
oui moi je demande à son docteur lui
s'est vu sur ton est à g qui te dis aux
gens de faire comme toi quand tu avais 6
ans et pas de copine et je fais toi moi
ouais ben déjà comment date
oui j'ai tenté l'expérience tu as que tu
peux voir des résultats de sa possible
mais je me tournais et qui pilote aussi
dégueulasse mais le juge je trouve ça
drôle c'est que j'ai gardées comme ça tu
étais totalement fasciné les conseils
j'ai vu ton post sérieux alors qu'un
coucou à ouidah et merci beaucoup aimé
ça vous va là bas